what these central details okay firstly
Lloyd amount okay so three hundred and
sixty thousand borrowed what's a lot of
money actually not that much compared to
some luggage that there at the motors
now just keep in mind though obvious
things in the numbers but not everything
this vital in this question is do you
marriage or at least spoken good so
equal monthly payments on what did you
say and dollars monthly repayments and
critically they're really nice to do
they say it's at the end of each month
that's kind of coded for you to say
interest is going to be applied and
we've seen a second and then the payment
comes later okay even when this is not
stayed in the bank will always sneak in
interest before you pay it because if
they calculate the interest before you
pay that means they get to add on more
interest so they make more often and
you'll say doesn't matter I'll just pay
a day earlier and I'll say the interest
in the early this and then bake up
always units okay
so monthly repayments and I'm going to
say end of month just as a signal to
myself um the length of the loan 25
years which is three hundred months why
do they think why do you think they give
us the number of months to help you
remember
it's a classic era that students make
when they do not include the number of
months if you say oh yeah you feel both
payments in the interstate 25 and they
have to pay off like $30,000 everyone
who think what went wrong
reduce your interest in these religious
all that these days you've got your big
sum of money and if you pay off some of
it up when they calculate the interest
it won't be on the original song it'll
be on whatever is left okay so it
reduces engine six percent per annum
interest now while I'm at it and this is
just an optional thing but you can see
even though the interest is per annum
the numbers per and they actually
calculate it twelve times a year
sometimes of you so therefore with this
at the same time while it's still in my
head while I write per annum interest
rate I'm going to write a per month
interesting what does that I don't sleep
tonight that's five percent yeah so zero
point five percent okay great we're
ready right let a and B the amount going
off the inter painted so a1 is after
from pay what's a two or three page
twice cetera taught one write down an
expression and there's just one mark for
it for the amount going after the second
month okay now I'm going to begin right
from scratch the reason why is this
comes up as Susan sequences in a minute
we're gonna have a geometric progression
Capilla and when you do any series how
many terms in the series do you need
before you have a pain the answer is
three right because if I say one there
two if it's an AP the next term would be
if it's an entry the next term would be
very angry right but if it's a GP the
next step will be oh so you really need
that third term to really capture it so
we're gonna do they give you a hallmark
just to do this first two so a one how
does it begin well you can see you
stopped at this amount and then you have
to get to a repentant right what happens
before the
okay so we stopped without a 360,000 and
then I'm gonna multiply by an amount
that includes the original 360,000 plus
the interest so it's going to be one
point one point one okay
now zero five was the most common era
before the HSC when this question was
done okay because one point zero five
sure looks like a pretty standard
interest rate to me
right it just happens to be wrong what
is the interest rate it's zero zero five
right because it's 0.5 of a percent
point five all the percent so it is in
fact one point zero zero five right
common area to me there's the first
application of interest but before I
call this a one there has to be a
repayment this is a one is the amount
going after these first my payment did
you say before one this to no good so
therefore I have to take away our
payment I don't know what the size of
the room is it's just designated there
so far so good
okay so now we're ready to see what
happens in the next month right then
going is going to be Nick he's the two
now there's going to be the second
payment before their payment there's
always interest right
so it's this amount a 1 and then they
apply interest to it right they do this
one point zero zero five again and then
there is a repayment okay now that's not
really the expression they're looking
for they want to stick span that out so
you can see every term up here is going
to get another one point zero zero five
so I'm going to get this that's got to
lots of interest apply to it this has
one interest and there's my most recent
repayments that make sense
yeah sure okay you mean this bit or this
business it's on you okay so let's point
out a couple of things firstly all it's
happening here
sorry month to month to month his
interest repayment interest repayment so
here this is whatever is left at the end
of that first month it gets interested
so that amount there can be color that
amount there gets an extra lot of
interest apply to it right and then this
will this can I hear the first repayment
it also gets an interest applied to it
okay if you want to think about it this
way you've got this original 360,000 all
right and after three hundred months
it's gonna learn it's in a girl a girl a
gardener and effort of writing the SAP
shows you two
it grows independently by the end of
this I will have three hundred
repayments sitting on the other side of
the ledger but most are growing and
they're eventually gonna grow up and
gonna cancel each other out and that's
when there's nothing left
Howie does that make sense okay
that's a to this your first month you're
welcome that wasn't soon amigo
okay and this step by step is really
important now already doing part